[Musica]
e va bene risposte
e basta
allora ragazzi ho fatto il game perché
hanno aggiunto un bordello di cose
nell'ultimo terzo giocato noto con
piacere che hanno fatto un miglioramento
anche al caricamento che ho fatto
veramente figo adesso da ragazzi hanno
aggiunto un sacco io posso lasciare le
note lo acquista una lettera che lascia
mese in poi hai voluto specifica bout
large no come anno a caccia dello
scrivere lancio pins essere incinta
school roof top spero che sarei
definisce ma è una cosa per sempre ma lì
finisce sepai siam sicuri nella cosa
giusta ma non è mica non è non è quello
di sempre
ma allora cosa me ne fotte chi è che ha
trovato la lettera scusami le persone
parlava lasciata senpai ma cosa me ne
fotte degli altri cui cos'è che chi è
questa che è rimasta qui perché non sei
andato in classico a del problema già
zia posso parlarti per un momento
secondo me ti piace il colore verde
non ne sono sicurissimo e vabbè ma la
madonna non volevo essere così cattivo
non pensavo facesse così subito va bene
sono sporco di sangue ma tutto ok
tranquilli alle mie cose quindi normale
vorrei solo dire che quel corpo che non
si fa così e che tu sei brutto perché lo
stesso tratto la vendetta
la vendetta di gesù
e stata na che che si muove borja della
madonna che si sta facendo tutti i
compiti in classe ma che sono accoppiate
non c'e la prof
non ho visto non ho visto mano visto
semplice perché non è come sembra è che
quando le mie cose sono in acqua l'unico
gioco della vita dove tenti niente in
pausa ma ti esce un toast in bocca
fantastico un mini senpai delle ali del
demonio vantano vanno aggiunto che cosa
mica è un'altra bella e basta ma questa
cialis pills sbircia sicuramente non ti
sta vedendo guarda sicuramente non mi
stanno tanto per niente da zia sei tu
che la destra il destinatario della
lettera se sei tuccio ha avuto un pool
incredibile o sei tu non capisco
l'inglese sono punto ci sono perché sono
in una bacinella di piscio mi fate
capire un attimo perché stiamo parlando
con una tettona quindi piacevole però
non capisco la sta dicendo
porca vacca che cosa ha voluto visto
vabbè ragazzi hanno aggiunto una piscina
ma e non ci sono ancora andato che
problemi o cioè il problema è che in
italia non abbiamo le scuole con la
piscina moto chini commenti misti l'età
la mia scuola che la la piscina
il mio scopo era già tanto sapere se era
una scuola allora già tanto sarà alle
classi ne ha tanto era proprio da
ringraziare di gesù cristo che avesse le
classi permesso che figata nevi che
posso fare i tuffi gli prego aspettiamo
quindi posso affogare la gente lo
scettro ris è l'album come visibilmente
armato a spiegare come potrebbe essere
un'arma lo scettro di serio bum bam
mi chiedo se qualcuno è mai ma è la
magia di ceo
si no
amica perché visto che c'è il retro
della scuola c'è la piscina almeno
mettiamolo lì che così non lasciamo
impronte in giro no al kalak annunci
sporto più completo della livello ed
essere gamberi e ragazzi altro che modo
le mamme che dicono è noto è lo sport
completo non è vero lei andò gli under e
uno sporadico 90 quanta forza fisica ci
sono venuto fin quassù per quello almeno
fallo ti prego a cagare va a versailles
sottoli estrae che va bene così pensano
che se però non ti emozionale troppo per
rifarmi che cazzo vuoi a lesbica quello
di sangue e k bastano hanno avuto
sospetti per un attimo e basta
e poi parlano a caso a quello è un morto
a ma sai che ieri mia zia cioè
laboratori di computer
[Musica]
ma invece di giocare a due tratti ne se
che non è che potresti fare curiosità
voglio capire come cassette misteriose
13 ma che ma 50 kg di peso ma siamo
sicuri maver ma per che cosa che va bene
the rock sia
c'è un problema non so questo ha fatto
malissimo
vabbè ragazzi siamo qua per non per
gingillare ma per far fuori delle
persone quindi gt che devo concentrarmi
per che avrai sono kato borgato linea e
gas
questa e benzina io vi do fuoco
raccontaci mi apro potranno farla la
fisica dell'acqua il suo gioco dalle
cuoche si può dare fuoco alla gente che
mi mancato passaggio era come faccia dal
fuoco la gente quindi attenzione ed è il
momento giusto per cui thorne
[Musica]
tana di tua madre ma stai zitto l'ha
fatto che grado sociali zia potresti
apparire di notte forte forte al tizio
che si dà delle arie lingue non ho
ancora visto cosa c'è qui dentro perché
c'è un ascia c'è un ascia della madonna
ma non ho mai capito perché possa
sfondarlo con lascia anche se capire chi
sa come foto il cargo le foto still the
shell chi faceva pe nun ce la farò mai
regga su fatta
no ci ho fatto no ciò faccio fatta noi
lato sono ancora lì ma credo di aver
cela in realtà semplicemente che la
tizia ce l'hai proprio disegnate sul
culo cioè quel computer quindi è infatti
cielo sarà disegnate proprio come il
personaggio va bene per rack poison c'è
qua dentro la sega che quella la trova
anche senza aprire le porte euro dico io
in conclusione ragazzi che gli andrà a
salutare anche vecchio amico così
concludiamo in bellezza ciao zio storia
io dovrei vincerla questa è però ma se
hai una staticità antico scelto problema
va dai ragazzi basta la stagione diventa
sempre più tragico ogni volta che lo
gioco però vi sia piaciuto spero che
abbiate imparato commesso degli han
anzi come non essere un highlander e
cosa sente vicino al momento che mi
piace anche la risorsa che con cellulari
tiziano se ne saresti fischiatemi ci
vediamo al prossimo vita della ragazza
a manila mia
[Musica]